hi here we are in week four can you
believe it we're going to be taking a
quick look at using your mobile devices
in your camera phones and we're also
going to take a very superficial look at
making videos superficial in the sense
that we're not going to teach you step
by step the idea is for you to use what
you've already learned which is an
extraordinary amount in terms of making
your still pictures and applying it to
making videos and we'll show you by
example of some very very interesting
videos that people have made of science
and engineering I'm going to take a look
at my notes here so we'll take a quick
look back natasha has some comments and
takes that you saw in the week about
life let me just quickly tell you who
natasha is natasha is the one
responsible for creating the videos in
terms of fabricating them all of these
tutorials the way we worked was the
following I just did not want to make
talking head tutorials it's not my style
and this is of course all about pictures
so the idea was for me to collect 20
years of images and some recent ones too
of course and then what I did was
created storyboards which then Natasha
collected the the images I gave her and
in over overlay the voiceovers that I
made and we went back and forth and we
edited this in that and then she added
some of her magic and that's how we got
the videos that we got which I think
work i hope you think they're working i
think that we're getting comments from
you that you're enjoying the videos
which is part of this it's not only
learning but it's enjoying the stuff
because otherwise why bother so if you
remember a while ago i said please read
your manual and your manual
talk about white balance some of you are
not balancing you like properly and that
we saw this more in this past week it's
very simple it's just a means of telling
the camera what temperature to adjust
the images for and and you'll you'll
find a better image I'd really rather
you do that here in while you make the
camera that make the pictures and not do
it in post production it's something
that you might want to look at ok so
that's it here we go in week 4 have fun